df très suivi raymond barre se fâche les
syndicats réplique sommet des neuf à
venise ils veulent changer les règles du
jeu européen
la transat incidents en série
l'oiseau fait demi-tour pajot toujours
en tête mais là messieurs bonsoir ce fut
une grosse grève le mouvement d'action
décidé par la cgt et la cfdt à l'edf
n'est pas passé inaperçu c'est le moins
que l'on puisse dire
ça faisait longtemps que l'on n'avait
pas assisté à d'aussi fort délestage
pour les consommateurs et de si fortes
de polémique les coupures de courant
enregistré ce matin et cet après midi
ont été en effet les plus importantes
intervenues ces dix dernières années et
le débat qui s'en est suivie n'est pas
prêt se refermer alors d'abord débat sur
les modalités vous avez coupé le courant
dans plusieurs hôpitaux dit le ministère
de la santé aux grévistes ce n'est pas
de nous répond t-il c'est la direction
de l'edf réponse à son tour la direction
c'est la faute des manoeuvres
intempestives de certains grévistes
débat également sur le fond et ça les
gars ont dévoyé le service public dont
ils ont la charge par la volonté de la
nation a déclaré le premier ministre
ils ont commis ou laisser commettre des
actes graves pour la sécurité les
personnes poursuit raymond barre c'est
inadmissible de la part d'agents qui
bénéficient de la sécurité d'emploi de
la garantie du poids bacha et d'une
protection sociale exceptionnellement
élevé le gouvernement a donc conclu
raymond barre veillera à ce que les
actes fasse l'objet des sanctions qui
s'imposent réplique de jean resseguie le
gouvernement se trompent lourdement
s'ils pensent intimider les travailleurs
et s'il ya sanction
raymond barre prendra la responsabilité
de l'aggravation de ce conflit alors
parlons maintenant du point de départ de
ce conflit précisément le problème de la
sécurité dans les centrales nucléaires
sécurité dans les centrales nucléaire
est un impératif
rien n'est laissé au hasard parce que
ces machines ont un fonctionnement
beaucoup plus compliqué que les
centrales classiques un réacteur
nucléaire est moins souple qu'une
chaudière au fioul
en cas d'arrêt sa remise en route
demande plusieurs jours et impose la
vérification de tout un tas de systèmes
pour être sûr que tout est normal
d'autre part les à-coups trop fréquents
fatigue beaucoup plus un réacteur
nucléaire qu un moteur classique il peut
s'ensuivre des défaillances qui sans
être très graves peuvent coûter très
cher le maniement des combustibles
nucléaires demande également beaucoup de
précautions et donc de sécurité
tous les employés d'edf des centrales
nucléaires sont très bien formés et
entraînés régulièrement pour la bonne
marche des machines mais aussi pour le
respect des règles de sécurité
en principe tout est prévu rien ne peut
se produire les hommes sont aidés par
des systèmes automatiques et par des
ordinateurs et même l'éventualité d'un
coup de folie a été prévu ce que edf
redoute le plus finalement c'est la
banalisation des gestes que les règles
de sécurité ne soient plus respectés à
la lettre
edf redoute aussi que des grèves à
répétition n'endommage des installations
on ne risque rien en fait puisque des
sécurités sont là pour éviter presque
toutes les catastrophes mais on sait que
le matériel nucléaire coûte cher
on sait aussi qu'un arrêt de centrales
pour fait de grève entraînera un arrêt
de production d'électricité beaucoup
plus long que la grève elle-même
l'aspect sécurité n'est qu'un alibi
n'est qu'un prétexte
en fait ce qui est visé par là c'est le
droit de grève aujourd'hui des agents
dans travaillant dans le nucléaire
mais demain de l'ensemble des gaziers
électriciens et voir des services
publics et l'ensemble des travailleurs
et tout ce qui affaiblit le mouvement
syndical a faibli l'ensemble des
travailleurs est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que cet amendement et jirau
puisqu'il s'appelle comme cela vise à
instaurer une sorte de service minimum
dans tous les services publics ou les
entreprises publiques mais le service
minimum existe depuis longtemps et df il
a toujours été remplies
sauf cette fois où la direction générale
a volontairement et délibérément
procéder à des délestages mordant même
sur le plan de pont rouge les consignes
que nous avions donné et qui ont été
respectées par tous devaient aboutir un
maximum de délestage de 60% la direction
refusant de se déconnecter de l'étranger
et de jouer sur la fréquence a provoqué
dès la coupure d'une partie du blanc
rouge y compris de certains hôpitaux
c'est la provocation et nous considérons
mal placé les leçons de sécurité de
responsabilité qui nous sont adressées
la cfdt ne va procéder à la provocation
et l'effort de son bon droit le droit de
grève est un droit inscrit dans la
constitution et nous considérons que
monsieur sera qu'une limitation d'aucune
sorte et sans aucun abus possibles
écoutes et de tout temps les gaz
électriciens ont su assurer la sécurité
et limiter l'usagé l'ordre du rêve
il n'avait pas de raison que ça ne
continue pas ainsi et je considère que
le cnpf est mal placé pour nous donner
des leçons alors que c'est lui qui casse
les entreprises c'est lui qui multiplie
les chômeurs et les nantis ne sont pas
les gaziers électriciens les
travailleurs savent bien faire la part
des choses
alors ça ne m'empêche pas d'autres
réactions sont d'abord des boulangers
dans le pétrin c'est lequel de dire que
manifester leur mécontentement à lyon
dans le var et dans le tarn en jetant
leur pâte à pain devant les directions
locales de l'edf le patronat indépendant
des pmi qui invite les usagers à retenir
1 % sur leur facture d'électricité
jacques blanc numéro un du parti
républicain qui dénonce l'abus que l'on
fait du droit de grève et yvon chotard
vice président du cnpf qui affirme sur
notre antenne à midi ne pas vouloir pour
autant remettre en cause le droit de
grève et enfin le parti socialiste qui
d'une manière générale s'inquiètent sur
le danger que selon lui cours en ce
moment le droit de grève
les libertés et la démocratie le sommet
de venise maintenant il s'est ouvert cet
après midi sur la petite île de san
giorgio c'est à dire pour ceux qui
connaissent venise à quelques centaines
de mètres de la célèbre place saint marc
cela commençait ce matin par un petit
peu de tourisme de la part de valéry
giscard d'estaing qui avant de déjeuner
avec helmut schmidt a remonté le grand
canal en bras de chemise pour aller à
l'institut saint georges les esclaves
autant vous dire que cette concentration
de personnalités affole quelque peu les
services de sécurité veut les voir avec
qui tu as vraiment comment il s'en tire
dans cette ville 100 ge
les pigeons de venise ont failli ne pas
s'y retrouver de la place saint-marc
jusqu'au dernier recoin de canal les
légions de touristes ont cédé la place à
des cohortes de soldats de policiers et
de carabiniers chargés de veiller sur la
sécurité des participants à ce sommet
des neuf paires à venise en redoutent
par dessus tout le terrorisme le
terrorisme qui ronge du têt avant
l'arrivée des chefs d'état on a tout
vérifié pas un pouce de terrain n'a
échappé à cette vérification est dans
cette ville bâtie sur l'eau des
plongeurs sont même allés inspecter sous
les piles est le grand canal et le lido
ils perdent sans doute un peu de leur
ambiance généralement plus insouciante
pour un temps cependant le calme ne
reviendra pas tout de suite après le
sommet des neuf qui maintient la police
italienne sur le qui vive
il y aura donc dix jours celui des dix
pays les plus riches du monde avec en
tête le président carter
alors parlons maintenant du fond des
discussions plus détendu dit ont d'ores
et déjà que lors des deux derniers
sommets puisque la crise qui oppose
londres aux autres capitales européennes
est désormais réglée en tout cas
officiellement on va donc pouvoir ouvrir
d'autres dossiers
georges bortoli notre envoyé spécial à
tunis ce décor ensoleillé le venise les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement
européens entendent bien ne plus se
lancer dans d'âpres discussions
budgétaires comme ce fut le cas à leur
dernière réunion
ils veulent rendre à cette notion même
de sommets ce véritable finalité c'est à
dire dégager les orientations générales
discuter de grands problèmes
internationaux
le proche orient pour commencer la
question étant de savoir comment les
européens peuvent faire avancer le
problème
beaucoup vous le savez pense à une
déclaration commune des 9 à la fin de ce
sommet certains préconisent même une
mission exploratoire de personnalités
européennes auprès des principaux
protagonistes du drame mais du côté
français apparemment on n'y croit pas
beaucoup
quoi qu'il en soit ici dans cette île de
san giorgio il y a une volonté commune
de ne pas gêner les initiatives
américaines pour la paix même si la
procédure de camp david n'a débouché
jusqu'à présent que sur des résultats
bien incertain et puis on parle aussi
évidemment de l'afghanistan et ça même
était le principal objet de la
conversation que monsieur giscard
d'estaing le chancelier schmidt ont
depuis tout à l'heure au déjeuner qui
les a réunis tous deux et puis enfin
puisqu'on est entre européens
on parle de réformer les institutions
européennes sous peine de voir l'europe
tomber dans la puissance et la confusion
et la sutie l'élément moteur concernant
le proche orient semble être monsieur
giscard d'estaing surtout l'élément
moteur concernant des réformes
européennes semble être pour l'instant
surtout le chancelier schmidt qui est
très désireux à la fois de réformer les
règlement financier de la communauté et
aussi de corriger certaines erreurs de
la politique agricole commune premier
ministre japonais monsieur on ira est
mort la nuit dernière des suites d'un
infarctus il avait 70 ans cabinet
japonais a démissionné dès l'annoncé du
décès monsieur y aura devait participer
au deuxième sommet de venise celui dont
vous parlez bruno alberta leur survie
des pays industrialisés les 22 et 23
juin prochain sera monsieur pitot qu'il
remplacera à la tête du gouvernement
j'en parlais hier soir les nouvelles
hébrides traverse une crise
d'instabilité à quelques semaines de
leur accession à l'indépendance le
gourmand de port vila réclame la
proclamation de l'état d'urgence c'est
pourtant sur ordre de paris les
gendarmes français qui étaient sur place
depuis mardi dernier vont quitter les
îles et cela alors que les anglais eux
arrivent
jean claude renaud comment conduire à
l'indépendance un chapelet de 40 il
perdu dans le pacifique sud
un condominium franco-britannique unique
au monde
la question est devenue sérieuse pour
londres et paris après les affrontements
qui ont fait un mort et quelques blessés
à tana une île au sud de l'archipel
un député d'opposition a été tué et sa
mort agréable conflit entre le
gouvernement issu du parti vanuatu qui
siège à port vila la capitale et les
partis d'opposition qui dans certaines
il souhaite obtenir leur autonomie
ainsi l'île la plus grande santos au
nord est entré en récession depuis le 28
mai les communications sont coupées avec
la capitale et le gouvernement de port
vila a décrété le blocus de lille depuis
ils réclament une intervention militaire
des français des britanniques qui pour
le moment ne souhaite pas l'épreuve de
force
quitte à repousser la date de
l'indépendance prévue pour le
juillet paris et londres préfère que les
néo hybride est réglé leur problème par
la négociation
cela dit si les cinquante gendarmes
français ont plié leur paquetage 200
marines britanniques arriveront à port
vila dimanche afghanistan les jours
doivent avoir mal à la tête de l'état
semblent comptés à kaboul les rumeurs se
multiplient et dans les rues de la
capitale afghane attention et fort qu'il
n'est pas trop soviétique plus
nombreuses ont renforcé les mesures de
sécurité
la loi martiale a même été décrété dans
deux villes politique maintenant la cfdt
propose une semaine d'actions contre le
projet peyrefitte est cependant qu'à
l'assemblée nationale les députés
débattent débattent depuis deux jours
donc des amendements apportés à ce
projet sécurité et liberté il faut bien
dire qu'au palais bourbon la halle père
est un petit peu retombée et aujourd'hui
daniel brême on a compté bien des
travées vides il y avait une quarantaine
de présents mais voyez-vous les
combattants s'affrontent depuis près de
quatre semaines
ils ont déjà beaucoup parler en
commission et ors de l'assemblée et
leurs arguments sont connus et surtout
il n'ya plus de surprise à attendre plus
dangereux puisqu'on sait que le vote du
projet est acquis puis ce sera
simplement une question de patience
puisque les socialistes ont l'intention
de faire durer les débats en proposant
de scrutin public sur tous les
amendements alors dont le défilé
classique des orateurs de cet après midi
j'ai noté que monsieur foyer avait
insisté sur le fait que l'approbation du
rpr était acquise parce que le projet
avait été profondément modifié ses
articles sur supprimer ou même 18 sur
les 60 et au passage il a glissé
quelques méchancetés pour les magistrats
les professeurs de droit et aussi
l'hiver le dso alors même position à
l'udf favorable de messieurs colombie
est longue et qui est encore réservé sur
un point dans le camp adverse monsieur
du colonel qui a recueilli les
applaudissements socialiste ce qui n'est
pas habituel mais il a les mêmes
positions a jugé que cette loi était
scélérate antisocial démagogique et
électoraliste et il a réclamé une
profonde modification du code de
procédure pénale pour relancer ce fameux
débat sur la peine de mort oui alors là
c'est monsieur fournier qui a protesté
et même avec agressivité puisqu'il a
traité le minent
3 d'hypocrites est le menteur et il a
regretté enfin il a protesté parce qu'on
essaierait pas la suppression de la
peine de mort dans ce texte
monsieur peyrefitte a rappelé que ce
débat qui était essentiel aurait eu en
toute sérénité au parlement après les
élections de 1981 et pour le reste il se
réserve de répondre lundi après avoir
entendu les 40 orateurs inscrits le
débat se poursuit ce soir
merci et bien justice toujours
précisément avec le procès des neuf
syndicalistes cgt inculpé de violence et
de voies de fait contre des agents de la
force publique
l'afer est toute récente c'était le 4
juin au moment de l'évacuation par les
forces de l'ordre du local qui abritait
radio nancy coeur d'acier claude
sérillon a suivi les débats du tribunal
correctionnel de nancy
foulards rouges l'ont calicots
banderoles d'unité syndicale slogan
inlassablement répété libérez nos
camarades lorraine coeur d'acier vivra
ce matin pendant deux heures plusieurs
milliers de manifestants cgt c'est l'été
venu de besançon de longwy de colmar ont
traversé nantes et cet après midi devant
le tribunal des flagrants délits c'était
le procès pour violences et voies de
fait sur agent de la force publique
il s'agissait pour les juges de ne
savoir précisément si les photographies
au nombre de 150 prises par des
policiers pouvaient apporter la preuve
que des militants cgt avaient jeté des
pierres des tuiles des parpaings des
bouteilles d'acide sur les forces de
l'ordre vient il s'agissait d'une
riposte à une agression nous étions en
légitime défense notre maison la maison
du peuple local syndical était attaqué
par des policiers répliquèrent les
militants cgt inculpé alors on ergote
rassure un cliché photos sur la couleur
d'une tuile et il faudra attendre la
venue des témoins responsables syndicaux
pour que le procès quitte le domaine du
droit commun le simple délit pour
devenir une tribune de la défense du
droit syndical mais de la radio libre
lorraine coeur d'acier
il n'en sera guère question on n'a
d'ailleurs pas retrouvé l'émetteur après
l'assaut de la maison du peuple à nancy
c'était déjà il y a une semaine encore
un mot des prétoires pour vous dire que
la cour de cassation a fait savoir
aujourd'hui à paris qu'un procès-verbal
pour excès de vitesse
repéré par un cinémomètre n'est valable
que s'il est signé par les deux
gendarmes celui qui contrôle et puis
celui this
quelques kilomètres plus loin mais peu
importe celui qui rédige grave attentat
orly la nuit dernière une bombe a
explosé dans un casier de consigne
automatique huit personnes qui faisait
le ménage ont été blessés une employée
l'a été grièvement les gabelous y sont
très importants presque toutes les
vitres de l'aéroport volé en éclats
l'organisation actions directes 27 28
mars a revendiqué l'explosion à
l'attentât qualifié d'imbécile est
scandaleux par le ministre transport
joël le theule et puis ce crime odieux
au bois de boulogne à paris un
déséquilibré a tiré avec une winchester
sur rue un groupe d'écolières de dreux
en visite au musée des traditions
populaires
une jeune fille de 15 ans est morte à
thann par quatre balles l'assassin s'est
ensuite livré à la police deux heures
après central sport la transat en
solitaire
cet après midi on apprenait le naufrage
du britannique tristone qui a dû être
recueillis il ya quelques minutes par un
cargo marc pajot sur le bateau d'eric
tabarly marche très fort et conserve la
première place au concours mais surtout
eric loizeau qui était en tête du
classement officiel a fait demi tour
hier soir ils causent à des vies
d'oiseaux qui était en tête de la
transat serait sur le chemin du retour
voilà la seule information que l'on
possède actuellement le jeune français
n'a toujours pas donné de ses nouvelles
de toute façon il ne pourrait
correspondre qu'avec des radioamateurs
ne possédant pas à son bord deux radios
suffisamment puissante l'oiseau dispose
d'un trimaran construit en bois moulay
selon les techniques de l'école
américaine de multicoques une longueur
de 13 mètres 23 pour un poids de 3
tonnes et demie
ce bateau avait déjà à son actif une
traversée de l'atlantique dans le sens
ouest est
traversée effectuée extrêmement
rapidement jugés 'sans 5000 km en 13
jours et demi depuis le début de cette
course on a constaté un nombre très
élevé de collisions de bateaux avec des
billots de bois qui ont eu pour
conséquence soit le naufrage du bateau
c'est le cas pour chacune site soit le
bris du pilote automatique c'est le cas
pour daniel gilard souhaitons peau eric
loizeau qu'il ne s'agisse que d'un
incident mineur qui n'affecte pas la
fiabilité de son bateau et regrettons
pour la course d'après tom grossman et
michael burch à notre favori de la
transat disparaissent ainsi du
classement
tennis vilas a déclaré forfait pour
wimbledon l'argentin doit être opéré
prochainement de l'appendicite football
une recrue de choix pour les girondins
de bordeaux le marseillais marius trésor
qui a signé un contrat d'un an avec ce
club
et puis championnat d'europe des nations
à turin les anglais absent de la
dernière coupe du monde deux rencontres
elle est belle des incidents ont éclaté
dans les tribunes les forces de l'ordre
ont alors utilisé des gaz fumigènes et
l' arbitre a dû arrêter la partie cinq
minutes avant la mi temps car les
joueurs suffoquait sur le terrain
finalement les belges et les
britanniques ont fait match nul 1 but
partout
demain vous pourrez voir ce match en
différé sur antenne 2 mais tout de suite
propose de revoir ses débuts avec
olivier rey est tout d'abord le premier
but anglais avec à l'origine un centre
de brooklyn wilkins récupère le ballon
jongle avec et marque un joli but que
l'on revoit au ralenti fort de cet
avantage on pense que les anglais vont
s'envoler vers une large victoire
mais quatre minutes plus tard sur ce
corner tiré par van moer les belges vont
égaliser grâce à coleman ce qui s'empare
du ballon et dont le tir soudain trompe
clémence le gardien
un partout ce sera le score final de ce
match de bien meilleure qualité que
celui qui a opposé hier la
tchécoslovaquie à l'allemagne de l'ouest
avant le tiercé l'autocar j'apprends que
le record a été battu hier un joueur a
gagné 940 millions de centimes près d'un
milliard de centimes avec la combinaison
qu'on donnait y est alors les résultats
du tiercé donc aujourd'hui il fallait
jouer le 13 là c'est le 24 une
combinaison qui rapporte
nous sommes allés voir plus modestes
dans l'ordre 50 2282 france 5 ans pas
mal quand même
et dans un ordre différent dit 1456
france 50 la météo aujourd'hui les
températures étaient relativement douce
plus de 20 degrés sur les côtes
atlantiques où il a plu alors pour
demain lors vous m ils sont vos
prévisions
ben écoutez je crois qu'il va falloir
prendre un parapluie et surtout ne pas
se mettre sous les arbres pendant les
trois prochains jours car il y aura
beaucoup d'orages horatio vous n'aurez
pas froid en effet températures sont
élevées 15 degrés le matin jusqu'à 25
degrés l'après midi
mais voilà ce qui se passe de l'air est
aspiré par le sud entre l'anticyclone la
zone d'un beau temps qui nous incitaient
malheureusement pour partir sur l'europe
centrale et la dépression qui suit
derrière sur l'atlantique
c'était revient du chili donc chaud mais
il se charge en humidité d'une part sur
l'atlantique et d'autre part cela
méditerranée alors plus on est au sud
puis jeunes de nuages et plus les orages
sont violents orages de lendemain dans
l'aquitaine le poitou les charentes ce
massif central également particulier sur
le sud du massif le versant exposés au
vent et puis également sauvé région de
la méditerranée
ici à l'ouest roussillon languedoc
plus on va vers le nord plus il y a des
petites chances ce d'éclaircies dans la
journée sauf à 3 minutes même les le
ciel sera encore plus nuageux et donc
quelques rares risque d'ondée à
caractère orageux sous les nuages avec
des petits coups de vent et puis tout de
même plus on va voir le nord plus on
retrouve le soleil et donc sur le nord
les frontières de la belgique le
nord-est et une partie de l'est du pays
près de l'anticyclone
dans toutes ces régions devraient avoir
quand même pas mal de soleil demain
comptant samedi et dimanche et bien je
crois que c'est le même temps qui va
continuer tout juste un petit peu
meilleure dans la moitié nord du pays
voyez chaque pas continuer dimanche
trois jours de grande instabilité sur la
france même si le temps n'est pas
totalement mauvais c'est un peu une
sorte de tende été orageux
merci laurent ce soir dernier rendez
vous avec l'information vers 23h20
c'était avec geof qui vous présentera le
journal et puis demain nos antennes 2010
paul lefèvre ouvrira le dossier explosif
de la prostitution avec une enquête
exemplaire d'une demi heure
voilà ce journal un petit peu plus court
qu'à l'habitude est terminée car je
laisse la place à mes confrères des
sports pour la rencontre espagne italie
le temps d'une page de publicité et je
vous retrouverai de m'asseoir si vous le
voulez bien pour soi